en las montañas de catherine la muerte
golpea repentinamente y a cualquier edad
este padre acaba de perder a su hijo de
nueve años está muy muerto en la
explosión de una mina el 11 de marzo en
este montón de plástico que ves aquí en
fue está muy quien lo recogió y me pidió
que fuera a venderlo a los recicladores
pensó que con ese dinero podríamos
comprar un teléfono porque no podíamos
costear un antes de su muerte no he
tocado ese montón del plástico y su
bicicleta tampoco había prometido
cambiar su rueda además de su pequeño
trabajo como recolector de plásticos la
mud ayudaba a menudo a su madre el día
de la tragedia fue con ella y su vecino
un amigo a recoger una planta de la
montaña cuando volvían a casa la mina
les explotó en la cara y cuando sus
madres corrieron a rescatarlos ya
estaban muertos mi hijo murió al
instante sin otro niño media hora
después los llevaron a cuestas
derramando sangre con sus cuerpos
destrozados todo el camino casa desde
2012 esta cordillera en la frontera
entre argelia y túnez se ha convertido
en escenario de enfrentamientos entre
militares e insurgentes islamistas
aprovechan el terreno accidentado para
esconderse mina
renault con artefactos explosivos para
dificultar el paso de los militares pero
las víctimas de estas minas suelen ser
los lugareños los que no tienen más
remedio que utilizar estos caminos para
asegurar su sustento para este padre de
cinco hijos es la única solución si
quieres seguir alimentando a su familia
no tenemos suficiente dinero para
comprar una vaca de génova 22 linares
algo menos de siete euros así que esto
es lo que comen las ovejas en su lugar
alfa antes las mujeres llevaban a los
animales a pastar directamente las
alturas ahora ya no quieren ir allí a
pocos kilómetros nos encontramos con
moke está que vive al pie del monte may
y la cerca de sidi buzid se salvó por
poco de morir al pisar una mina docta
nos muestra con su muleta los lugares
del pie donde la mina le golpeó una mina
explotó justo debajo de mi pierna y salí
volando por los aires he tenido lesiones
aquí aquí además una aquí
como aquí había ido a recoger romero las
minas están colocadas en una trayectoria
definida y nosotros cuando nos vemos
obligados a salir de la pista no sabemos
cómo evitarlas porque están dispersas al
azar en la actualidad él y su esposa
esperan una ayuda estatal ya que no se
atreven a aventurarse en las montañas
ahora tengo mucho miedo si me dieran una
compensación económica creo que me iría
no quiero seguir aquí
las autoridades no hacen pública las
cifras de muertos y heridos por
artefactos explosivos pero sólo este año
murieron tres civiles y cuatro soldados
ante esta amenaza el gobernador local
trata de contener el éxodo rural que
desde hace años afecta fuertemente a la
región
nuestras fuerzas de seguridad están
haciendo grandes esfuerzos para luchar
contra los grupos terroristas de la
región en kasserine y en otros lugares
para nuestro deleite
esto nos permite ganar tiempo para
tratar de encontrar soluciones para que
los residentes puedan seguir viviendo en
sus casas además de este esfuerzo en
materia de seguridad
la versión urbana el estado también
trabaja en el frente social y económico
y hacemos todo lo posible por apoyarles
económicamente estima ya para algunas
familias el conflicto ha puesto sus
vidas patas arriba como aquí al pie del
monte salud cerca del pueblo de hash y
el ferry en kaserín en 2018 esta casa
estuvo en el centro de una lucha entre
quijada vistas y militares nos cuenta un
familiar de los que vivían allí de forma
anónima
eso es una ronda y este agujero aquí
también
un agujero de bala y aquello otra aquí
las fuerzas de seguridad dispararon
desde este lado y los terroristas desde
el otro nuestros soldados lograron matar
a uno desde entonces el lugar está
abandonado demasiado expuesto a un
posible regreso de los yihadistas los
yihadistas vendrían en grupos de tres
como mínimo pero podría llegar a grupos
de 12 personas a menudo bastaban y
pedían agua y comida por ello la familia
se vio obligada a avisar a las
autoridades esta casa no se puede vender
por esa razón se hizo demasiado conocida
en el sentido por lo que pasó algunos
todavía intentan resistir como este
joven periodista independiente que
heredó una parcela al pie de la montaña
chan de los barridos militares en el
maquis yihadistas son muy frecuentes
eso es un pistacho eso es un olivo y eso
es un almendro
para él no hay que dejar la región en
manos de los insurgentes islamistas los
vecinos sólo queremos recordar estas
regiones y el estado debe animar a los
agricultores a permanecer en sus tierras
proporcionándoles un lugar donde vivir o
acceso al agua para regarlas ahora mismo
lo único que tenemos es esta carretera
que permite al ejército ir y venir
reduce mi terreno a la mitad pero es
nuestro único logro en los últimos años
al menos tenemos una carretera
pavimentada la trata de asse le prometió
un sistema de riego hace cinco años se
ha construido una primera mitad pero
sigue siendo inutilizable las obras
están paradas y no se vislumbran su
recuperación ante la consternación de
los habitantes nos pusimos en contacto
con el ministerio de defensa para
conocer mejor la estrategia de lucha
contra el terrorismo en el país pero no
respondió a nuestras peticiones